[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANJALI JOSHI: So welcome
everybody to Google.
My name is Anjali.
And I'm a VP in the Next
Billion User team at Google,
focused on India products.
Today, I have the
immense pleasure
of welcoming a living
legend, the very
talented and internationally
renowned Asha Bhosleji.
Ashaji is perhaps the most
senior artist in Hindi films
who is still performing.
She started her career in 1943,
in pre-independence British
India, and is
still going strong.
And not only have you
grown up on her songs,
your grandparents have as well.
Her first song was
recorded at the age of 10.
And today, she is still singing.
She's done over a
thousand Bollywood movies.
In addition, she's recorded
several private albums
with many other stars.
And she has sung
over 12,000 songs
and is in "The Guinness
Book of World Records."
[APPLAUSE]
The government of
India honored her
with the Dadasaheb
Phalke Award in 2000
and the Padma Vibhushan in 2008.
Ashaji.
[APPLAUSE]
Ashaji, welcome to Google.
We are so honored and
privileged to have you here.
And you can see by the
enthusiasm in the audience,
everybody is really eagerly
waiting to hear from you.
Let everybody settle
down and then we'll
start with questions.
OK?
You can all take photos later.
Is this your first
time at Google?
[SPEAKING HINDI]
[LAUGHTER]
ASHA BHOSLE: [SINGING IN HINDI]
[SPEAKING HINDI]
[APPLAUSE]
ANJALI JOSHI: Can you
roll the video, please?
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- What was more fun?
Was it more fun singing
songs for RD Burman
before you married him or
after you became his wife?
And also another
question was, what
is your most favorite
memory of recording
a song with RD Burman?
Anything you can think of?
Any memory of recording
a favorite song of yours
with him?
I would just love to
come and see you today.
Take care.
We all love you so much, Ashaji.
Bye-bye.
[END PLAYBACK]
[SPEAKING HINDI]
[APPLAUSE]
ANJALI JOSHI: Please
roll the video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Hello, Ashaji.
This is Vikosh.
Welcome to Google.
[SPEAKING HINDI]
--like there's no singer for me.
And I love songs--
Thank you.
[END PLAYBACK]
[SPEAKING HINDI]
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
ANJALI JOSHI: Can you
please roll the video?
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Hi, Asha.
This is Cliff.
Thank you so much for
speaking with us today.
I'm a big fan of yours.
My first exposure
to your music came
with the collaboration you
did with the Kronos Quartet.
I was humming "Dum
Maro Dum" for ages.
I wanted to see if you had any
stories from that or thoughts
on the broader collaboration
between playback singers
and more Western
styles of music?
[END PLAYBACK]
[SPEAKING HINDI]
ANJALI JOSHI: Mischievous.
Rebellious.
ASHA BHOSLE: Rebellious.
[SPEAKING HINDI]
ASHA BHOSLE: [SINGING IN HINDI]
[SPEAKING IN HINDI]
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
ANJALI JOSHI: Which song
would you like to sing?
[SPEAKING HINDI]
ASHA BHOSLE: [SINGING IN HINDI]
ANJALI JOSHI: Thank you.
Thank you.
I hope you enjoyed that.
So now I want to change to
a slightly different topic.
And perhaps you all
don't know this,
but Ashaji is an excellent chef.
And she runs many, many
restaurants across the world.
[SPEAKING HINDI]
[LAUGHTER]
So could you please play
the trailer, please?
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Utshob.com and Stardust
presents Asha Bhosle live
in concert--
- [SPEAKING HINDI]
- --on 12th August, San Jose;
19th August, New Jersey;
20th August, Boston.
Also featured with Javed Ali.
- [SPEAKING HINDI]
[END PLAYBACK]
[SPEAKING HINDI]
[APPLAUSE]
[LAUGHTER]
ANJALI JOSHI: Zanai,
could you come on stage?
[APPLAUSE]
[SPEAKING HINDI]
[LAUGHTER]
ZANAI BHOSLE: Ah,
female infanticide
is like a really big problem.
[SPEAKING HINDI]
ANJALI JOSHI: You
can talk in English.
It's OK.
ZANAI BHOSLE: So we're
going to give them money.
Quite a bit that we
get from the show,
we're going to donate it
for saving the girl child.
And my grandmother has
a charity for everyone.
And we're going to
donate some money in that
as well, so this
doesn't take place.
And we have people like
my grandmother not killed
at such a young age.
[APPLAUSE]
ANJALI JOSHI: So
Zanai, how has it
been for you to be working
with your grandmother?
ZANAI BHOSLE: It's the most
beautiful experience ever.
Because being on the same
stage with her is like--
it's amazing.
And I'm getting
this opportunity.
I'm lucky.
But at the same time,
she's my grandmother.
ANJALI JOSHI: Of course.
ZANAI BHOSLE: So it's
very, like, also relaxed.
I know that somebody
is there for me.
ANJALI JOSHI: What are
the types of new pieces
or new things that you're going
to be singing in the concert.
ZANAI BHOSLE: I'm thinking--
OK, if I tell you that,
then there's no point.
But I will tell
you that I've been
listening to my
grandmother and my grandad
since I was very young.
And for me, they
are my inspiration.
They are my everything.
So I'll be singing
something like that.
I won't tell you
what I'm singing.
ANJALI JOSHI: I also heard that
you sing in other languages.
ZANAI BHOSLE: I do.
But I have to develop it.
I'm working on it.
ANJALI JOSHI: Can you sing?
ASHA BHOSLE: They'd like that.
ANJALI JOSHI: Come on.
You have to listen to your
grandmother, one little song.
[SPEAKING HINDI]
ANJALI JOSHI: OK,
a couple lines.
The audience would
like you to sing.
ZANAI BHOSLE: In Hindi?
ANJALI JOSHI: Whatever.
ZANAI BHOSLE: [SINGING IN HINDI]
ANJALI JOSHI: Thank you.
ASHA BHOSLE: Marvelous.
[SPEAKING HINDI]
ANJALI JOSHI: Are you
going to be singing
a duet with your grandmother?
ZANAI BHOSLE: Yeah.
ANJALI JOSHI: That
will be wonderful.
Shall we sing another
song together?
That was so much fun.
Which song would
you like to sing?
[SPEAKING HINDI]
ASHA BHOSLE, AUDIENCE:
[SINGING IN HINDI]
[APPLAUSE]
[SPEAKING IN HINDI]
ANJALI JOSHI: Thank you.
Thank you.
[SPEAKING IN HINDI]
[APPLAUSE]
[LAUGHTER]
ANJALI JOSHI: Thank
you very much.
[SPEAKING HINDI]
ANJALI JOSHI: You
know, we've actually--
she's already sung a lot for us.
And we have promised her
that we would not be making
requests for her to sing.
So I would leave it to you.
[LAUGHTER]
[SPEAKING HINDI]
ASHA BHOSLE:
[SINGING IN HINDI] Ratio
[APPLAUSE]
ANJALI JOSHI: And my
favorite, which is [HINDI],,
one line from that, and
then we will finish.
And that is specially
dedicated to my father,
who listens to it every day.
ASHA BHOSLE: [SINGING IN HINDI]
[APPLAUSE]
ANJALI JOSHI: Thank you so much.
It has been an immense
pleasure and honor
to have you here at Google.
And I cannot tell you
how grateful we are.
[SPEAKING HINDI]
ANJALI JOSHI: Thank you.
Thank you.
[SPEAKING HINDI]
ANJALI JOSHI: Despite
everybody saying, please
don't ask her to sing, I think
you have done us a great honor
by being with us, by sharing our
memories, by singing with us,
by having us sing with you.
And we have truly, truly enjoyed
having you here at Google.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[SPEAKING HINDI]
ASHA BHOSLE: Thank you.
Thank you very much. thank you.
[APPLAUSE]